president Trump's DOJ opens a criminal
probe into the Trump Russia
investigation we lay out the two
theories of trumps Ukraine activities
and there are new developments in the
case of a seven-year-old boy being
treated as a girl by his mom in Texas
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored
by expressive VPN protect your online
privacy today at expressvpn calm / Ben
love myself some expressive VPN okay so
the big news of the day is that the
Justice Department is apparently going
to open now a criminal inquiry into the
Trump Russia investigation and the media
are already playing defense on this
thing the media are already suggesting
that this thing is wildly out of bounds
just to get this straight it was totally
inbounds when we spent two-and-a-half
years spending millions of dollars
investigating the Trump Russia collusion
nonentity it ended up being a big
nothing burger at least the collusion
part of it the obstruction part of it
and a piggy backing off of that and
really was only generated by the
presence of the Trump Russia collusion
investigation in the first place that
was totally fine
that was aboveboard that was good it was
good to have the DOJ investigating the
President of the United States which
effectively is what the Trump Russia
Muller investigation became that was all
good
wonderful according to the press but
when the Trump administration looks into
the origins of the Trump Russia
collusion investigation which may or may
not have been badly founded well then
it's a terrible thing a very very bad
thing it's something that William bar
clearly should not do is just William
bar the Attorney General being a
political hack there are no legitimate
questions to be asked so we'll get to
what exactly William bar is
investigating here and whether it is
legitimate but first if you're noticing
there may be a lot of chaos out there
then you might be thinking to yourself
how can I invest that the chaos doesn't
actually eat my savings the fact is when
there's a lot of chaos in the world
whether you're talking about chaos in
the Middle East or whether you're
talking about cows domestically at home
people tend to once put their money in a
safe haven and that safe haven
traditionally has been gold gold right
now is sitting at its five-year high
which is not a particularly shot given
the amount of chaos in the universe at
large right now I've been telling you
for years that if you're not protecting
your investments and your family with
gold the way that I have you're missing
the boat should at least diversify I'm
not talking about taking all your money
and then cash it into gold and then take
it and store in your mattress I'm
talking about taking
of your money and diversifying into an
asset that is not going to depreciate at
the behest of the federal government
inflation national debt global
instability all of this can really have
an impact on your savings it can really
have an impact on your investments it's
one of the reasons again why you should
diversify well how can you do this well
you can first check out my friends at
Birch gold they'll go to work make
things super simple for you they'll have
a conversation with you and you can
determine if precious metals make sense
for you ask all your questions get all
the information make an informed
decision if you haven't yet taken the
first step of requesting a free
information kit
on gold you should know it's not really
a complicated process there's no
obligation you have nothing to lose by
taking that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
views and a plus rating with Better
Business Bureau again you should have at
least a little bit of precious metal in
your investment portfolio text Ben - 47
47 47 today to see how simple and
straightforward the move can be for you
again that is Ben - 47 47 47 text Ben -
47 47 47 okay so the New York Times
obviously very hot and bothered about
the prospect of William bar looking into
the Trump Russia collusion investigation
my friend Andrew McCarthy over at
national review the legal analyst he's
been suggesting from the very beginning
that this thing was basically a put-up
job that effectively speaking the Obama
administration was eager very eager to
look into the Trump campaign and as soon
as they started receiving notes on the
steel dossier from the Hillary campaign
they were ready to go they're ready and
they're raring to go and it turns out
that they couldn't dig up anything
before the election that was truly
damning of President Trump but there
were at least slow leaks along the way
and McCarthy's dear in theory of a lot
of other people is that basically a lot
of members of the so-called deep state
members of the intelligence community
who didn't like Trump who feared Trump
who thought that Trump would be a
terrible president they were digging up
all this material in case Trump should
be elected so that they could then break
glass in case of emergency and basically
sideline his presidency by pushing into
investigative territory right that is
the going theory so according to the New
York Times today for more than two years
President Trump has repeatedly attacked
the Russia investigation portraying it
as a hoax and illegal even months after
the special counsel closed it now from
Sohn Justice Department has opened a
criminal investigation into how it all
began now there was already an
investigator generated in
an inspector-general Michael Horace
who's going to release a report a public
report he said today it'll be a public
report there will be no private version
or classified version and public version
there will just be one version and it
will be a report into how all of this
started now my theory has been that this
thing was started not under false
pretenses but under authentic concern
over the activities of people like
cutter Paige and George papadopolis and
that it quickly morphed into something
that went beyond its original mandate it
quickly morphed thanks to people who are
all fired gung ho to go get Trump into
let's look into every one of trumps
associates and all his business
connections let's suggest that President
Trump is in fact a plant of Vladimir
Putin and all the rest of us but what
does it mean that this is now shifted
into a criminal investigation well it
means that the Justice Department now
has additional legal tools at its
disposal according to the New York Times
Justice Department officials have
shifted an administrative review of the
Russia investigation closely overseen by
William bar to a criminal inquiry
according to two people familiar with
the matter the move gives the prosecutor
running it John Durham the power to
subpoena for witness testimony and
documents to convene a grand jury in to
file criminal charges now here's where
the New York Times starts playing
defense for the Democrats normally that
would be the story right they've opened
the criminal investigation
the New York Times however does what
they are so fond of doing people say
this is serious journalism now they're
not gonna say we the editorial board the
New York Times really object to this
instead what they do is they sort of
they kind of slide into the DMS they
just slide into the reporting other
people's opinions the opening of a
criminal investigation is likely to
raise alarms that mr. Trump is using the
Justice Department to go after his
perceived enemies okay that's called
editorializing right they're likely to
raise alarm is likely whenever they use
passive voice like that they're not
saying who is going to raise the alarms
Democrats they're not saying who is
going to be seriously concerned that
Trump is militarizing the Justice
Department the New York Times they just
say it's likely to be perceived that way
but you know people who people just
people say mr. Trump fired James Comey
the FBI director under whose watch
agents opened the Russia inquiry and has
long assailed other top former law
enforcement and intelligence officials
as partisans who sought to block his
election mr. Trump has made clear he
sees the typically independent Justice
Department as a tool to be wielded
his political enemies this is in a news
article guys right this is in a news
article Trump has made clear he sees the
DOJ is his personal tool okay yeah and
Eric Holder called himself Barack
Obama's wingman so you know it turns out
that presidents have long sort of seen
the DOJ as a way of pursuing their own
agendas doesn't mean it's good when
Trump does it it just means that to
pretend that this is unique to Trump is
to ignore American history according to
the New York Times that few factors into
the impeachment investigation against
him as this is long obsession with the
origins of the Russia inquiry House
Democrats are examining in part whether
his pressure on Ukraine to open
investigations into theories about the
2016 election constituted an abuse of
power the move also creates an unusual
situation in which the DOJ is conducting
a criminal investigation into itself and
then they say well you know the real
reason that Barr is doing this is that
he can use Durham as of runs like this
is the entire article is just
speculation about how corrupt Barr is
right now they're not waiting for the
report to come out and at no point did
they ever suggest that the emptiness of
the final Trump Russia collusion report
from Robert Muller invalidated the
investigation to begin with
right the investigation was valid
according to the New York Times it was
just that it didn't come up with the
answer that they wanted but here they're
trying to invalidate the entire
investigation before they even know what
the results are which is frankly kind of
trumpian and its approach to the
investigation and this is the New York
Times they say mr. Bauer's reliance on
mr. Durham a widely respected and
veteran prosecutor who has investigated
CIA torture and broken up mafia rings
could help insulate the Attorney General
from accusations he is doing the
president's bidding and putting politics
above justice it was not clear what
potential crime Durham is investigating
nor when the criminal investigation was
prompted okay so you don't know anything
about the investigation you just know
there is one so the New York Times
immediately calls it corrupt and then
they get into more of like Lee's right
there perspective people who are likely
to see things a certain way they say mr.
Trump is certain to see the criminal
investigation as a vindication of the
years he and his allies has been trying
to discredit the Russia investigation in
May Trump told Fox News host Sean
Hannity that the FBI officials who
opened the case had committed treason
when Barr appointed Durham's lead the
review he had only the power to
voluntarily question people and examine
government files but now the criminal
investigation is open that means that
there are new tools at their disposal
so the New York Times obviously is very
upset about all of this revelation so
far about germs investigation have shown
he is focused in his first month on the
accusations that Trump's conservative
allies have made about the origins of
the Russia inquiry in their efforts to
undermine it Durham's efforts have
prompted criticism that he and Barr are
trying to deliver the president a
political victory though investigators
would typically run down all aspects of
the case to complete a review of it so
now they're already forecasting the
results of this thing before it comes
out which reads like preemptive spinning
does it not it reads like they are very
much afraid of what's going to be in
Durham's final report here they're
afraid of what's going to be in the
inspector general Michael Horowitz this
report and so they're already trying to
spin it away as well it was it was a
selective investigation done at the
behest of the President of the United
States in interviewing more than two
dozen former and current FBI and
intelligence officials mr. Durham's
investigators have asked about any
anti-trump bias among officials who
worked on the Russia investigation and
about one aspect of the investigation
that was at the heart of highly
contentious allegations that they abuse
their powers the secret application
seeking a court order for a wiretap on
Carter page law enforcement officials
suspected that Paige was the target of
recruitment by the Russian government
which is not Carter page by the way was
never prosecuted at any level for this
sort for the sort of activity in which
he was involved and for which he was
investigated some CIA officials are
already retaining criminal lawyers it's
not clear whether Durham is scrutinizing
other former top intelligence officials
as well derm has indicated he wants to
talk to the people who ran the CIA in
2016 to find out how this whole thing
started he has not yet questioned either
John Brennan or James clapper as
Durham's investigation moves forward
according to the New York Times the
Justice Department Inspector General is
wrapping up his own inquiry into aspects
of the FBI's conduct in the early days
of the Russia investigation among other
things Michael Horowitz is scrutinizing
it the application for a warrant to
wiretap mr. Paige so this whole article
is basically speculation that some sort
of corruption is going on in
investigating the investigators as
opposed to you know you could just wait
until you find out whether the
investigation of the investigators comes
up with something damning hey I
encourage people to wait on the Muller
report I did go back and listen to it
for years hey I'm now encouraging people
to wait on the IG report and on the
Durham report you don't have enough
information but the New York Times is in
waiting
they've already declared this thing a
corrupt attempt by Trump to swivel the
DOJ to punch his political opponents and
that seems like fairly bad journalism
Inge from where I said okay in just a
second I want to get into a recap of the
Trump Ukraine allegations because it's
all confusing I understand I mean
there's a lot going on there a lot of
moving pieces and I want to for just a
few minutes go through and explain piece
by piece have this whole thing fits
together how there are two plausible
theories of Trump's activities in
Ukraine how the media are only treating
that as one plausible theory but there
really are two plausible theories we're
gonna get to that and I'm gonna give you
all the details and how all that fits
together in just one second first let's
talk about life insurance
I know who wants to talk about life
insurance because that means he now have
to think about death and who really
wants to think about death right that's
terrible who wants it well the fact is
if you don't if you don't think about
the future that awaits all of us then
you are unlikely to actually protect
yourself from things that can harm your
family I mean the fact is if god forbid
something happens to you they lose a
source of income how are they gonna pay
for your funeral how they're going to
take care of themselves be an adult go
get life insurance and it sounds
intimidating it sounds like it's gonna
take a long time it doesn't have to this
is where policy genius comes in policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in just minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will then handle all
the paperwork and the red tape for you
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance as well
so this month take the scariness out of
buying life insurance with policy genius
go to policy genius come get quotes
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone this very instant
they probably should because I'm not
gonna happen in the next five minutes
and neither do you
go check out policy genius calm right
now policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance ok so I
want to take a minute now and explain
the Trump Russia allegations where we
currently stand because there is so much
floating around and it's very difficult
to break down and you're hearing wild
allegations from all sides on the part
of Republicans you're hearing this is
all closed doors stuff behind closed
doors Democrats are simply prying
information out of people and then
they're twisting that information in
public and from Democrats hearing we
have the
information that is going to condemn
President Trump to removal by the Senate
so where are we the answer is or kind of
where we've been for the past few weeks
there's more information that is now
sort of filling out the gaps that we
were that we had at the very beginning
of this entire debacle but the fact is
that until in the end we hear from
either Trump or Giuliani nothing is
gonna change here why because they're
right now two plausible theories of what
Trump was doing in Ukraine and what
Trump was withholding military aid in
order to do in Ukraine and those two
plausible theories it's it's basically
choose-your-own-adventure time well when
it comes to Ukraine
this is choose-your-own-adventure time
and you get to pick which of these two
theories you think is more plausible so
let's spell this out so according to the
media Bill Taylor right this was the big
thing this week was Bill Taylor the
acting chargé d'affaires of the US
Embassy in Ukraine the highest-ranking
foreign official in Ukraine delivered
the coup de Gras to the Trump presidency
Ready's according to the media this was
the end of the Trump presidency he has
no defense and you're seeing this
repeated in the New York Times you're
seeing this repeated in Politico why
well because Taylor testified before
members of the House committees leading
the Democrats impeachment inquiry behind
closed doors but his opening statement
was revealed to the public well that in
and of itself has driven Republicans up
a walk they're like okay well he gave
his opening statement but then you
didn't reveal anything he actually
testified so these sorts of selective
leaks this is why we are complaining
about the behind closed doors stuff and
as we'll see the media are very angry
Republicans for complaining about this
how could they possibly complain gets
that in a bit
okay so Taylor's theory of Trump's
behavior was pretty simple right Trump
withheld the hundreds of millions in
congressionally authorized military aid
to Ukraine in order to benefit himself
politically going into 2020 in
particular by leveraging the aid to
pressure the Ukrainian government to
investigate his potential 2020 opponent
Joe Biden and Biden's son hunter right
all the other corruption stuff that was
kind of a smokescreen for him trying to
impact the 2020 election by doing
something politically beneficial for
himself right that was the that's the
will called the get Biden theory right
that is Bill Taylor's theory is the
theory of the media that Trump was
trying to shape the 2020 election by
having Ukraine go and do his dirty work
for him
and withholding military aid to make
Krang go do his dirty work that was the
that was the Bill Taylor theory
it's not implausible right the timeline
fits Trump keep saying dumbest stuff
publicly that sort of undermines his own
position on this right he he has said
he's not averse to asking foreign powers
to target his political opponents right
he he openly called in 2016 from
Vladimir Putin to release Hillary
Clinton's emails he asked the Chinese to
investigate Joe Biden right Trump says
this kind of stuff all the time so it's
not implausible right and to to be
perfectly fair about where we are we
have to recognize that that theory two
independent ears is not implausible
right that's why the polls are not in
president Trump's favor on the
impeachment stuff and I'm not gonna lie
to you and pretend that the American
people are wildly angry about
impeachment know a particular segment of
the American people are wildly angry
about impeachment a particular segment
of the American people are
extraordinarily excited about engagement
and then there are the people in the
middle we're trying to figure out what
actually happened here and our sort of
wavering on the fence okay so that's
theory number one is the get Biden
theory then there is another plausible
theory this one we'll call the miasma of
corruption theory okay it's still not
great for Trump but it's not great for
Trump in a non impeachable way so the
the get Biden Theory's story is a story
of a scheming president who is seeking
re-election by twisting American foreign
policy to his political benefit right
that's the story Trump is the guy who's
sitting there and he's trying to skew
foreign policies that he'll get
reelected and he's trying to withhold
American military aids that he'll get
reelected the miasma of corruption
theory characterizes Trump differently
it's the story of a president who's
being Petty and vindictive and obsessive
about the 2016 election not about 2020
about 2016 and following bread crumbs
left for him by his personal attorney
Rudy Giuliani it's the story of a
president who doesn't actually trust his
foreign policy establishment because he
believes that they are there to
undermine him and a president who
believes conspiracy theories and refuses
to let them go even when the evidence
doesn't really match up so which of
those two sounds more like Trump the guy
who is like a laser focused on 20/20 and
radies skewed things that he can so that
he can win 2020 or the guy who is
obsessed about 2016 talking about his
crowd sizes
doesn't trust his own people and so he
brings in Rudy Giuliani and creates
irregular channels and then buys
whatever information confirms whatever
pre-existing bias he already had so in
this story this is a story
quid pro quo not to help Trump in 2020
but a quid pro quo to target this miasma
of Trump perceived corruption that the
President believes led to the Russian
collusion narrative the damage his
legitimacy and say he has been obsessed
since 2016 with the idea that Democrats
are undermining his victory by saying
that Russia interfered in the election
he's saying no Ukraine interfered in the
election the American people have a
right to know just the way you say they
have a right to know if Russia
interfered we have a right to know if
Ukraine interfered and as part of all of
that if Ukraine interfered maybe one of
the ways that they interfered is by not
going forward with an investigation of
Democrats in the middle of the 2016
election including Joe Biden right so if
the second theory is true then Trump was
acting wrongly and stubbornly and
foolishly and on bad information but he
didn't commit an impeachable offense
because the stuff he was trying to
target in his own mind was in America's
interest it was not just in Trump's
interest so in Story number one again
this comes down to your judgment at
Trump's character which is why it's a
Rorschach test in Story number one Trump
is the strategic thinker who initiated
the Ukraine scandal deployed rudy
giuliani to go after Joe Biden
militarized our aid to Ukraine to help
Giuliani left the Ukrainians high and
dry in the face of Russian aggression
because he likes Putin in Story number
two Trump was led astray by Giuliani and
his own rich sense of grievance but it
was much more about 2016 than it was
about looking forward to 2020 so which
of these theories is more plausible well
let's go to the evidence as I start with
Rudy Giuliani and look at the timeline a
little bit here so this all begins with
Rudy Giuliani
Trump's personal attorney right this
whole story begins with Giuliani so in
June 2017 well it really starts with
Biden and Biden's whole deal with with
you with his son and his son working for
Purisima and then Biden withholding
ucroe Ukrainian loan guarantees and and
until they fired a prosecutor who
allegedly was going to look into hunter
Biden case that allegation was floating
out there and was floating out there
thanks to the New York Times by the way
which reported on him and then there
were allegations in 2017 that Hillary
Clinton was coordinating with the
Ukrainian embassy in order to create in
order to find dirt on Donald Trump right
that was reported by Politico the DNC
actually had sent an operative to the
Ukrainian embassy to gather all this
data that's the backdrop okay then we
got to Giuliani
so in June 2017 Rudy Giuliani visits
Ukraine and he meets with the president
of the
time again in Petro poroshenko and a
prosecutor named yuriy lutsenko in
August 2018 Giuliani is hired by a
company run by Lev Parnas who's
Ukrainian businessman and Giuliani
clearly begins to funnel information
provided by Parnas as well as Parnassus
partner
Igor Froman to trump in late 2018
harness and Froome and fix up Giuliani
with a former Ukrainian prosecutor named
Victor Shokan as well as Lu Cheng ko
right according to Lysenko Giuliani
Giuliani pushed him to open
investigations into the Biden's and
Purisima according to the New York Times
Giuliani met with lysenko multiple times
in January 2019 allegedly asking what
Sanko about Purisima the Biden's and
Marie
Jovanovic the American ambassador to
Ukraine and Giuliani told Trump about
these conversations in March 2019 but
saenko opens two investigations one in
Tabriz m'a and wanting to the Biden's
and according to The Times let's ankle
accuses ivanovitch of a corruption as
well and Trump starts tweeting about all
of this stuff so at this point certainly
it is plausible that Rudy Giuliani is
out there to quote unquote get Joe Biden
to get BER yzma it's also plausible that
as Rudy Giuliani himself later says he's
actually out there to defend his guy
from the Trump Russia stuff by targeting
Ukraine right which ties back into 2016
not forward into 2020 by April Trump is
telling Sean Hannity that Attorney
General William Barr might consider
allegations about Ukrainian interference
in the 2016 election which by the way he
actually is doing right now stuff is
being investigated right now by April
29th
Jovanovic was being recalled The Wall
Street Journal later says that rajul
eonnie was actually telling Ivanovich
telling Trump they Ivanovitch the
Ambassador was quote obstructing efforts
to persuade Kiev to investigate former
Vice President Joe Biden okay
fast-forward to May of this year the New
York Times reports the Giuliani was set
to visit Ukraine they said Mr Giuliani's
planned trip which has not been
previously reported as part of a
months-long effort by the former at new
york mayor and a small group of Trump
allies working to build interest in the
Ukrainian enquiries their motivation is
to try to discredit the special counsels
investigation undermined the case
against Paul manna for mr. Trump's
imprisoned former campaign chairman and
to potentially damage mr. Biden the
early frontrunner for the 2020
Democratic presidential nomination so
Giuliani then does an interview with Fox
News in which he talks about his theory
that Ukraine worked with the claim
campaign in 2016 and discuss the Biden's
days later Trump says to political it
would be appropriate to ask Attorney
General William bar to open an
investigation into the Biden's Trump
says I've not spoken him about it what I
speaks him about it I haven't thought of
that all of this is the backdrop to
Trump's decision to pressure Ukraine
so was Giuliani telling Trump can'twe of
quote-unquote getting Biden or is he
telling Trump that bad actors in Ukraine
had covered up Ukrainian election
interference in 2016 and Biden related
corruption here as was so juicy ani had
sort of tweeted out about this in June
of 2019 Giuliani is again the key figure
when it comes down to it all right so
Giuliani had tweeted out about all of
this in 2019 in in May of 29 June rather
of 2019 he tweeted out that the
president was going to that there had to
be some sort of investigation into
Ukraine and 2016 and abidance right it's
all it's all one big ball of corruption
it's one big ball of corruption that
language was then parodied by Trump so
again was Giuliani coordinating with
Trump to get Biden or was Biden merely
part of this broader ball of corruption
that Giuliani was supposedly attempting
to fight including fighting the Trump
Russia collusion narrative by looking
into a Ukraine Hillary collusion
narrative we're not going to know this
until Julian testifies either way Trump
decides to withdraw the military aid
from Ukraine contingent on Ukrainian
public commitments to fight corruption
which now in Trump's mind include both
2016 election interference as well as
the Biden's even today
Giuliani continually insists that his
Ukrainian efforts were not an attempted
to go after the Biden's really they were
into defending his client Trump
presumably from charges of Trump Russia
collusion in 2016 and not aims at
targeting Biden specifically he tweeted
out yesterday that his job is to defend
Trump from all charges rather that was
his goal here which is again
retrospective about 2016 not really
looking prospectively toward a 2020 day
but both theories are plausible and when
you get into more of the evidence in
just one second so you can see how an
honest person can see the interpretation
the Bill Taylor interpretation and how
an honest person can also see the
president Trump case that he has not yet
made but will end up making because it
is most likely to be true okay we'll get
to that in
just one second first let's talk about
your child's success so right now there
are a lot of folks in the media in
politics who are very angry at parents
who are pursuing their child success
like very angry at them they're more
focused on equality than the success of
children well if you are a good parent
you're constantly focused on how can I
make sure that my kid has the best shot
at succeeding and this is where varsity
tutors comes in you remember when you
are a kid and you needed a tutor and the
way you got a tutor is he sort of asked
around the neighborhood for somebody who
knew math and then that person came over
and the person kind of stared at your
math book for a while and then gave you
the wrong answer and then got paid 50
bucks if they were expensive and then
they left well instead of that you could
actually have a fantastic well-trained
tutor this is where varsity tutors comes
in whether it's in person or online
varsity tutors connect students with
expert instructors and anything from
early reader phonics to SAT test prep to
college courses unlike other programs
varsity tutors has a rigorous tutor
vetting process that ensures your child
is working with the best tutors from the
top schools in the country their online
live learning platform is a two-way
video chat and collaborative work board
to make learning easy and convenient
they've got a four point nine out of
five satisfaction rating you can empower
your child today
I've tried varsity tutors with my own
daughter they really are fantastic they
make it incredibly easy and the tutors
are really really high-quality to
receive up to 250 bucks and a free
consultation with an education director
go to varsity tutors comm /ban that is
varsity tutors dot-com / Ben for 250
dollars off give your kid the confidence
and keys to success today at varsity
tutors comm / men don't be shamed into
mediocrity instead give your kid weight
and give your kid go to varsity tutors
comm / Ben okay so back to the two
Furies of this Trump Ukraine stuff okay
so the next piece of the puzzle so we
have Giuliani's activities right we now
know that Rudy Giuliani was wandering
around Ukraine funneling information to
Trump via corrupt Ukrainian
businesspeople and prosecutors who were
saying that Ukrainian corruption
involved willful overlooking of Joe
Biden and hunter Biden and burries MO
okay now we get to the phone call right
this is the famous transcript of the
phone call so according to that
transcript - that July 25th phone called
it that initiated this whole mess
between Trump and ukrainian President
Vladimir zalenski Trump asked zalenski
for a favor because quote our country
has been through a lot and Ukraine knows
a lot about it I would like you to find
out what happened with this whole say
with Ukraine they say CrowdStrike I
guess you have one of your wealthy
people the server they say Ukraine has
it they say a lot of it started with
Ukraine whatever you can do it's very
important you do it if that's possible
so here what what the hell is from
talking about well he is referring to
the baseless conspiracy theory that
Russia was framed by Ukraine for the
2016 hack and supposed and subsequent
release of a damaging tranche of DNC
emails which involved a supposedly
secret DNC server being spirited away -
and hidden in Ukraine and this theory
has no evidence to back it and Trump
seems to be asking his olenski to
investigate the conspiracy theory
presumably in the hopes that this will
then remove the taint of Russian
interference from the 2016 victory
Solinsky then responds by mentioning
Giuliani because this is the source of
the information and from jumps on the
mention saying crude quote Rudy very
much knows what's happening and he has a
very capable guy if you could speak to
him that would be great and then he adds
there's a lot of talk about Biden son
that Biden stopped the prosecution and a
lot of people want to find out about
that so whatever you can do with the
attorney general would be great so is
this calll evidence of Trump seeking a
quid pro quo to quote unquote get Biden
or a pressure campaign to fight Trump's
Giuliani fueled idea of corruption
including but not exclusively focused on
Biden in Ukraine
okay now fast-forward to the text
messages are going through each piece of
evidence here and you can see how it all
fits within each one of the two theories
they're a series of text messages that
have been revealed between the
ambassador to the European Union Gordon
sunland special envoy ukraine kurt
volker
and taylor in those texts Volker says
quote after explaining as says that
after explaining these fixed up a
meeting between Giuliani and Ukrainian
representative quote most important is
for zalenski to say that he will help
investigation and address any specific
personnel issues if there are any and
then Volcker later reiterates quote
heard from White House assuming
president Z convinces Trump he will
investigate get to the bottom of what
happened in 2016 will nail down date for
visit to Washington
good luck so it appears that American
diplomats have basically accepted that
Trump is just listening to Giuliani now
and then pleasing Giuliani and then
therefore pleasing Trump is the key to
restoring aide Taylor is incredulous
about all of this right he reads the
investigations as a pretext for getting
Biden from the start he says are we now
saying that security assistance and
White House meeting are conditioned on
investigations he texts again as I said
on the phone I think it's crazy to
withhold security assistance for help
with a
campaign and Gordon Sunland response
quote bill I believe you are incorrect
about president Trump's intentions the
president has been crystal clear no quid
pro quos of any kind the president is
trying to evaluate whether Ukraine is
truly going to adopt the transparency
and reforms that President zalenski
promised during his campaign
I suggest we stop the back-and-forth by
text okay so that brings us forward to
the actual perceptions of the people
involved in the text that be Gordon
Sunland specifically as well as the as
well as Bill Taylor the the charge
d'affaires in Ukraine so Sunland submits
written testimony again we haven't seen
the full testimony which is part of the
problem here Republicans want the public
to see the full testimony Democrats want
to hold it back at least for now so
sunland's written testimony suggests his
own confusion about Trump's agenda he
acknowledges that quo corruption poses
challenges to the legitimacy and
stability of government corruption is
also an economic issue
he also says quote President Trump was
skeptical that Ukraine was serious about
reforms and anti-corruption and he
directed those of us present at the
meeting to talk to mr. Giuliani his
personal attorney about his concerns it
was apparent to all of us that the key
to changing the president's mind on
Ukraine was mr. Giuliani
and then Sunland says based on the
president's direction we were faced with
a choice we could abandon the goal of
white house meeting for zolensky which
we all believed as crucial to
strengthening us Ukrainian ties and
furthering long-held u.s. foreign policy
goals in the region or we could do as
president Trump directed and talk to mr.
Giuliani to address the president's
concern someone says he didn't
understand until much later Giuliani's
agenda might also have included an
effort to prompt the Ukrainians to
investigate VP Biden or his son or to
involve Ukrainians directly or
indirectly in the president's 2020
reelection campaign he also says he
spoke to Giuliani in short conversations
in which Giuliani quote/unquote
emphasized that the president wanted a
public statement from president zalenski
committing Ukraine to look into
anti-corruption issues Giuliani
specifically mentioned the 2016 election
including the DNC server and burries
ma-- has two anti-corruption
investigatory topics of importance for
the president he denies that Biden was
ever specifically mentioned in these
conversations Sunland does and he also
says that his statement that no quid pro
quos has taken place came directly from
conversations with Trump here's what he
said in his testimony quote I asked the
president what do you want from Ukraine
the president responded noting there is
no quid pro quo the president repeated
no quid pro quo multiple times this is a
very short call
the president was in a very bad mood
which is not either rare or surprising
okay that brings you for two tailors
testimony and this of course is the big
testimony right this is the testimony
that's gonna end from his presidency
according to the media so in contrast
with someone's lack of clarity on
Trump's agenda cuz someone is clearly in
the ball of corruption category the
miasma of corruption theory Taylor seems
pretty clear on this thing right Taylor
seems convinced the entire Giuliani hunt
was about Biden specifically and that
Trump withheld the aid in order to
target Biden right that's that and that
all of this really in the end was about
affecting 2020 his written testimony
repeatedly suggests as much like Sunland
he says he found that Giuliani was
actually running the Ukraine show he
testified quote by mid-july it was
becoming clear to me that the meeting
president zalenski wanted was
conditioned on the investigations of
buries my and alleged Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 elections it
was also clear that this condition was
driven by the irregular policy Channel I
had come to understand was guided by
Giuliani right that's exactly what
someone says later he says he realized
security assistance was also conditioned
on those terms but again it's not clear
whether all of this is conditioned on
generalized investigation of corruption
regarding 2016 or whether again this is
about affecting 2020 for the president's
political benefit Taylor obviously
believes the former he says the
determined investigations quote was used
to mean matters related to the 2016
elections and the investigations of
burries m'a and the Biden's but were
there open questions to ask about the
Biden's in other words would Trump have
to be motivated by a simple desire to
quote unquote get the Biden's rather
than to wrap up the buries mabye Dhin
investigation in the broader rubric of
fighting corruption in Ukraine and issue
the term carrot about because he was
personally invested in the 2016 election
and feels that his legacy has been
tarnished by all the Trump Russia stuff
my Trump found all of the surgeon
because he'd read the media coverage
about Ukraine's cooperation with
Hillary's campaign in 2016
believes conspiracy theories about
CrowdStrike believe that maybe Ukraine
is where all the answers were hidden
about 2016 okay that brings you forward
to Mick Mulvaney statement so Mulvaney
is Trump's chief of staff right and he's
been roped into this debacle because
Trump ordered him to effectuate them
withholding of the military aid
he gave a pretty disastrous press
conference in which he talked about
Trump engaging in a quid pro quo but his
comments didn't clear up the nature of
the quid pro quo itself was it about
Biden was it about 20/20 or was it
from perception of Ukrainian corruption
Mulvaney's suggested latter and he said
did he also mentioned to me in the past
the corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely no question about that but
that's it and that's why we held up the
money look back to what happened in 2016
certainly was part of the thing that he
was worried about in corruption with
that nation and that is absolutely
appropriate so how about Trump's
statements as always Trump never helps
himself right he continually breathes
life into the worst theory events he
says he'd like to see China investigate
Joanne hunter he says he'd accept
information about political rivals from
foreign sources he continually cites
Giuliani mound silliness about obvious
conspiracy theories but that doesn't
change the basic question was this an
attempt to get Biden or a petty foolish
misinformed intend to fire attempt to
fight the corruption that he thinks
targeted him in 2016 and more to the
point did Trump commit an impeachable
offense when one second we're going to
discuss whether Trump in all this
committed the impeachable offense and
why these two theories end up mattering
why this is the crux of the whole
impeachment argument gets that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that a lot of cars on there were a
lot of different types of car on the
road and because there's so many
different types of car on the road can
you really be assured that if something
breaks in your car you got to go to an
auto parts store they're gonna have what
you need well they're just gonna give
you some generic part that kind of works
maybe and it's overpriced but maybe it
doesn't work instead why don't you use
this thing called the interwebs it's
really fantastic and on the interwebs
you'll find something that is amazing
it's called Rock Auto comm it is a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to Rock
Auto comm to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil and even new carpet whether
it's your classic or daily driver get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door the Rock
auto comm catalog is super easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices best of all prices at Rock Auto
calm always reliably low the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers go
to Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about us box and they don't be
selling you that helps us on the show
helps them know that their advertisement
helped direct you to them it also helps
them because I mean the fact is they
want to know if it's if it's effective
to talk to you the ben shapiro show
audience so go check them out
Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for that car or truck
and right Shapiro in there Hara in there
how did you hear about us box okay
so in just a second we're gonna get to
the bottom line question is this stuff
impeachable but first you have to
subscribe go over to daily wear comm 9
ends in a month 99 bucks here you know
the whole squeal plus we now have our
long-awaited magical app it is here it
is fantastic I mean it is a beautiful
app if you are a subscriber you can now
access all of our content including
articles shows and more directly from
the app all access subscribers get our
new exclusive discussion features where
they can interact directly with hosts
writers special guests the app is
available on Apple and Android so
download it today become a subscriber
come join the fun it's a party on over
here come on join us
daily wire.com we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so now we get to the crux of
the matter is this impeachable so the
answer to that depends on whether you
believe the get Biden theory or the
miasma of corruption theory now are
these mutually exclusive can you believe
that what Trump was actually trying to
do was look into 2016 but also also
affect 2020 by going after Joe Biden
could it be both well here is the
problem the theories are only mutually
exclusive because the get Biden theory
forecloses the possibility that Biden
could have ever been investigated as
part of a generalized non twenty20
oriented push to investigate Ukrainian
corruption in other words if there was a
dual intent then the dual intent makes
it impossible to discern whether this
was in fact a corrupt quid pro quo right
if Trump had in his mind yeah Biden was
part of this whole 2016 corruption
Ukrainian corruption Fiasco and if that
affects 2020 then sure I guess it
affects 2020 or right it affects 2020 if
it affects 2020 good I'm glad right that
is not something that is discernible
right there's no way for you to actually
discern whether that's criminal or not
because it's just too vague what this
would have to be is a concerted attempt
to effectuate an American policy to help
Trump in 2020 by targeting an American
citizen and it's not even enough to say
that it's an attempt to affect 2020
generally because guess what virtually
everything a president does is attempted
to affect his reelection possibilities
right virtually everything on economics
on foreign policy all of it has to do
where the president's reelect
possibilities so it simply too brought
an argument to say foreign policy is
being directed toward helping a
president yeah I mean again every
president does that the question is
whether Trump did something criminal and
withholding military aid by going after
Joe Biden specifically in order to go
after Joe Biden specifically an American
citizen initiate a corrupt investigation
into Biden in from a foreign government
in order to affect 2020 so dual use is
not a possibility under the get Biden
Theory the answer as to whether the
Biden's could ever be legitimately
investigated by Ukraine
thanks to pressure from you Trump is the
distinguishing points in the to theory
so under the get Biden theory the
answer's no even as part of a broader
Ukrainian anti-corruption push any
mention of Biden turns that push into a
corrupt effort to use American taxpayer
dollars to attack a political rival in
skew 2020
under the miasma of corruption theory
investigating the Biden
doesn't automatically mean that Trump
was aiming at 2020 electioneering purely
rather he was obsessed about 2020 to
2016 and wanted everything he'd ever
heard from Rudy Giuliani investigated on
that score so your theory of Trump's
impeachment comes down to which of these
two theories you find more plausible as
I've been saying all along now here's
the big problem they're only two people
really we're gonna be able to answer
this question right Trump himself can
answer the question but is unlikely to
Rudy Giuliani could answer the question
and this is the thing that should scare
Trump if in fact Rudy Giuliani was
delegated by Trump to Ukraine to go get
Joe Biden let me a problem Giuliani's
got a big mouth and he goes on TV and he
says dumb crap all the time which is why
Trump's closest allies are telling him
tell Rudy to shot your head shot his
head like to stop the face needs to stop
moving look enough okay so it's really
down to trump and Julian which I've been
saying for weeks right for weeks I've
been saying until Rudy Giuliani
testifies all this other stuff is just
third party perception of of first-hand
knowledge right bill Taylor's perception
of events is not the same thing as Rudy
Giuliani being ordered by Trump to do X
because Bill Taylor's perception is
closer to the events than mine but in
effect he's still hearing stuff
secondhand and the same thing is true
with Gordon some would write as Gordon
someone and apparently and apparently
Taylor totally construe this differently
in one way we're gonna know the truth
one way or the other but now at least
you understand the theories now at least
you see how all of this plays out okay
now I want to get to the latest on this
Texas case so as you know there's been
this case we've all been following it in
which there's a seven-year-old named
James younger and there's a ruling that
came down from a court that originally
was going to grant sole custody to this
kid's mother doctor Angie or Gilles
Joerg Liz according to the father has
been since the age of three and doctrine
aiding this kid to believe that he's a
girl has been telling him that he is a
girl in fact there is tape of this kid
being asked when he's three years old
why he thinks he's a girl it's
disturbing here is what it sounds like
you're a boy right yep I'm a girl who
told you you're a girl mommy when did
she tell you you were a girl
huh I love girls oh I see
so mommy told you you're a girl huh so
mommy puts you in a dress and puts nail
polish on you and and what does mommy
tell you do you think you're a girl
uh-huh
you do is that why you wear this so that
you can have long hair okay so mommy
tells me I'm a girl
hey that's pretty disturbing stuff mommy
should not be telling a boy that he is a
girl that is child abuse it is I'm sorry
it is the telling a three-year-old boy
that he is a girl not even humoring him
telling him that yes indeed you are
correct you are a girl that's child
abuse it's your job as a parent to
parent your child not to humor his his
fantasies about life yeah well here is
the latest development in this case
according to the Daily wire
Amanda presto giacomo reporting on
Thursday judge Kim cooks ruled Texas
father Jeffrey younger has a say in his
seven-year-old son's gender transition
which is being facilitated by the boy's
mother and youngers ex-wife dr. Angie or
glass younger is attempting to halt the
boys transition cooks of the 255th
district ruled that the parents will
have joint conservatorship over James
which includes making joint medical
decisions for the child
however cooks also placed a gag order on
younger so that he can't speak to the
press about the case and decided the
father is not required to pay attorneys
fees which means the younger save James
website which has circulated videos of
James testimonials and vital court
documents will have to be shut down
pursuant to the order so now that means
that if mommy continues to manipulate
the case and then the judge rules for
sole conservatorship he won't have been
able to say anything or he will be in
danger of violating a gag order so it
sounds more like the judge is just
saying listen we don't like all this
public scrutiny we don't like the Greg
Abbott stepped in right the Texas
governor said he would investigate and
send Child Family Services to
investigate he doesn't like the Ted Cruz
mouthed off about it and Dan Crenshaw he
doesn't liked it people like me mouth
off about it right so the judge is just
saying well you know what let's just
keep going with what we've got going
here and you don't say anything you shut
up there's no gag order on Joerg list by
the way right as far as we know there's
no gag order on Joerg list so she can
continue to put up pictures on her
website of her son in a dress and talk
about her modern parenting methods which
is apparently something that she does
and she's a doctor and her medical
practice website until recently
according
Matt Walsh had a picture of her and her
son up there him wearing a dress which
is incredibly incredibly invasive for a
seven-year-old child and what you're
seeing is that the the media are being
denied access before the judge handed
down her verdict she kicked out all
media sources including the Texan Daily
Mail and LifeSite News as well as ABC
CBS 11 and while ABC CBS 11 and NBC were
reportedly allowed access but all family
and friends were kicked out and anybody
who covered this thing skeptically
that's according to LifeSite news
reporting from the Texan says the G org
list is lawyers Jessica Janicek and
Laura Hayes claimed during the trial the
mother does not plan on giving James
hormone blockers at this time but no one
has stated that Joerg list would not be
open to using them when James begins
puberty which is when he is like eleven
and a half so you know people who are
reporting that she's about to start
using hormones it's not true but she
says nothing would stop her presumably
she was she would she could start using
hormones on him at eleven and a half and
and the father couldn't do anything
about that plus she obviously gets to
continue to indoctrinate her child in
the belief that he is in fact a little
girl when by all biological metrics he
is not a little girl he is a little boy
and confusing children about this stuff
is nasty it does not protect their
innocence it does not help them the vast
majority of children who say that they
are members of the opposite sex end up
ends up abandoning that belief as they
get older okay the whole thing Joerg
list is July 2018 testimony apparently
reveals that if James persists is set to
be evaluated for hormone suppressants as
young as age 8 and this is just
incredibly disturbing stuff now is funny
a couple of weeks ago you may remember
that people got very uptight with me
when I said that I do not like the idea
of the state being able to tell me how
to parent my child I don't want that the
state should be able to shut down my
religious school on the basis of my
religious school being offensive to
their ears and I wouldn't like it if the
D if the state decided that they were
going to shut down my ability to
home-school my child and that if I moved
States and became federal policy that
there would be no place for me to go and
if it came to the police showing up at
my door calling me a truant parent and
threatening to remove my child from my
home because I can't parent my child the
way that I see fit then I would meet
those people at the door with a gun if I
had no other choice right if I had no
choice it was not voting is no longer an
issue where I mean some
shows up at your door to take your child
away voting is not really the issue
remember I got myself in all sorts of
angry waters and Twitter but it got so
mad about us by the way
that's called the Constitution of the
United States when fundamental rights
are absolutely breached and are
unchanging and now you're faced with a
violation of those fundamental
constitutional rights the Declaration of
Independence and Constitution are pretty
clear on this okay so that's what I said
we are now living in an era where it is
considered a fulsome good for the state
I mean the state was this close to
telling his father he could not that he
had to treat his son as a girl according
to media reports that he would be forced
by the state of Texas to treat his boy
as a girl and if he did not he would be
removed from custody of his own son
don't tell me that the the sort of
debates that we have on politics in this
country don't have very personal
ramifications for parents and how they
treat their children don't tell me that
this is all about non-interventionism
and kindness and protection it is not is
about invalidating particular points of
view is about invalidating what I
believe to be decent and good parenting
namely it is your job to guide your
child not to humor their their delusions
when they are three years old or five
years old or seven years old hey this is
this is what I'm talking about when the
state becomes a weapon of the social
left to the point where parents are
having their children removed from them
and then the state has become too much
of a danger so I'm glad the court backed
off of this I'm glad that the Texas
government stepped in and decided to
investigate all of this that is the
right thing to do but don't tell me it's
Fantasyland when I say that there are
folks on the Left who absolutely would
like to invade your home and not only
tell you how to raise your child but
mandate via the state how to raise your
kids or threatened remove them because
that's basically what happened in this
case at least originally as reported by
the way Matt Walsh makes a great point
in this Walsh was all over this he
writes for us over at daily wire and he
was really terrific on this issue his
attention to this issue that probably
created a lot of the firestorm that led
to the government of Texas stepping in
he points out something that is quite
important right he says that if you read
all of the reports of this this kid when
he was three right was saying that he
was a girl but he wasn't just saying he
was a girl he was saying actually
that his first name was Starfire right
interestingly the amicus attorney Dunlop
revealed that your gloss told him that
Luna was not the first female name that
James picked out the first was Starfire
a female character from the superhero
cartoon Teen Titans go Joerg was however
encouraged him to pick a different name
Walsh says while this shows what realm
James was living in when he allegedly
claimed you as a girl he was in the same
realm of every normal child inhabiting
from infancy until adolescence the realm
of fantasy he wasn't they identify as a
girl who's identifying as a cartoon girl
there's no substantive difference
between this self-identity and the
self-identity of my own three-year-old
boy who regularly claims to be a
dinosaur a bear a bear hunter a shark or
sometimes all four he said kids at that
age have no understanding of reality in
theory or practice this is me now that's
why they have parents right to guide
them through that stage of development
not to humor their fantasies he Walsh
says the fact that James identified not
just as a girl but as a cartoon girl
should make it pretty clear that this is
magical thinking and psychological
immaturity
he also says reflect on the fact that
James's mom it didn't let him go by
Starfire this is an amazing point right
the fact is that Jaime's mammals like
you-know-what starfighters too much we
can't do Starfire instead we're gonna
call you Luna
so just to be straight about this a
three year old kid can decide that he is
a girl but can't decide his name is
Starfire we I mean it would be crazy let
him go through life thinking that he's a
person named Starfire that would be
totally wild but letting him go through
life and encouraging him to go through
life believing that he's a member of the
opposite sex not only is that legitimate
that's solid parenting according to the
members of the social left Walsh says
indeed it is striking that these
painfully progressive parents who want
their children to have the freedom to
choose their own gender still won't let
them choose their own names there's a
reason why trans kids always have names
like Luna or jazz or sky or Parker or
something similarly ambiguous in trendy
do we think three and four-year-olds are
hopping on to Google to find out which
unisex monikers are in fashion at the
moment know if you left it to a young
child to decide for himself they'll
inevitably gravitate toward something
like Starfire or ninja or pirate poop
but all of these options would be better
than Luda but they still wouldn't look
great on resume but you never end up
with the trans daughter named pirate
poop Potter Starfire because even
Angelus knows her son is too young to be
entrusted with
choosing his own name and then
eventually he'll grow up and won't be as
fond of the name he liked when he was a
child what sort of idiot parent would
allow her young son to make that kind of
decision knowing how immature he is and
how certain it is that he will grow out
of this phase we don't let our kids
choose their names for the same reason
we don't let them get tattoos correct
correct
okay but this is it's not alarmism to
say that the social left would love to
parent children parent your children and
take your children away from you and
tell you that you're not allowed to
determine how you want to parent your
child than they will militarize the
power of the state if they can in order
to accomplish this that is not alarmism
that is the thing that is happening on
rare occasions in the United States but
over time this will be come increasingly
volatile it'll be increasingly bad this
is gonna become mainstream policy within
ten years in the Democratic Party isn't
it this is not its fringe right now
ain't gonna be French for long not the
way the media are treating this issue
not the way Hollywood treats this issue
and certainly not the way that Democrats
are treating this issue already going
along with every I mean basically
Democrats are five seconds away from
declaring it child abuse for you to say
to a three-year-old child who says that
he is a girl and he's a boy that he is a
boy right there that's already happening
up in Canada so to pretend that this is
not a coming issue is to ignore the
reality on the ground but this is what
you see so often from the left why are
you guys being so alarmist we would
never do anything like that not and then
five seconds later they're doing exactly
that five really five seconds later okay
time for a quick thing that I like and
then maybe a thing that I hate maybe
okay so quick thing that I like today so
I have decided that a couple of years
ago I I was going through the Bible week
by week we've just and I feel like now's
a good time to sort of get back into
that now you don't have to be a believer
in the Bible to sort of find inspiration
in the Bible or to or to think about
some of the deep messages of the
founding document of Western
civilization and the most read book of
all time right it still seems relevant
even if you are not a believer in the
ability and the veracity of biblical
stories even if you're not a believer in
God per se it is important to understand
where your civilization came from and
some of the thoughts that are embedded
at the deepest levels of what you would
consider myth but what people who are in
religious circles would consider to be
God
God's story about the world the story
that God tells us right so so this week
restarts the Jewish canonical cycle so
we've reached we reached the end of
reading the Torah every year the Jews
read through all five books of Moses we
read portion by portion one every week
and this week we finally finished the
final portion of the Torah visio
Sabratha this is the five books of Moses
and we'll restart from the beginning of
Genesis so for a second I just want to
talk about one of the more bizarre
stories in Genesis of course the very
famous story probably the most famous
story in the Bible and that would be the
story of Adam and Eve it's a very weird
story right I mean just on the face of
it it's a very weird story you've got
God going around telling people they can
eat from certain trees and not eat from
other trees and then you've got a snake
who shows up and says it's talking snake
and he shows up and he says to a lady
well you know if you eat from that tree
everything is you're gonna be like god
you're gonna know the difference between
good and evil and then she eats from the
tree and sure enough her eyes are open
and suddenly she knows things she didn't
before and God gets pissed and he throws
everybody out of the garden where I mean
that's that sort of the short version of
the story but what is this thing
actually about like why does this
actually have serious meaning so there
are all sorts of interpretations now one
present one interpretation that I think
fits really well with the Hebrew text of
this section of Genesis so there is a
the biggest question about this story is
what is actually wrong with knowing good
and evil remember the entire story is
predicated on God saying you can eat
from every tree in this garden in fact
you should eat from every tree in this
garden but there's one tree candy from
and that is the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil you can't eat from that
one do not don't do it I'm telling it
just don't it ain't gonna end well and
Eve is the snake into eating from
entries so the question is why is it bad
to eat from the tree of knowledge of
good and evil you know more stuff now
right now can't you make more moral
judgments you know good you know evil
you got a knowledge of good and evil
what's the big problem okay and all of
this seems pretty harsh because as soon
as this happens God is like okay well
now you're gonna die you're gonna sweat
live by the sweat of your brow you're
gonna suffer in childbirth I mean the
snake actually sort of gets it right
when you read the biblical account right
the the because God says to Adam it
really says to Adam if you eat from that
tree on that day you will surely die
thanks yeah well the snake says quote
you will not surely die for God knows
that on the day you eat thereof your
eyes will be open you'll be
angels knowing good and evil and sure
enough the snake seems to be correct
right God's first words after the sins
who the Angels behold man has become
like one of us having the ability of
knowing good and evil
and then God gets ticked off so what
exactly did they do wrong well so to
understand the problem first we have to
define our terms good and evil so the
only reference terms that we have for
good occur before this in Genesis right
at the very beginning of Genesis when
God is creating the universe so in the
very first chapter of Genesis God
creates the heavens and the earth and
then he would he labels things good
right by our Hashem Kito right now
there'll be the the Hebrew right he saw
that it was good and then there was
evening and there was morning.the first
day right that that is constantly
repeated God creates something he sees
that it's good and it's evening in this
morning a day so what does that mean
that it's good right what what does it
mean that his creations are morally good
that light is morally good that the the
creation of animals that that's morally
good know that the the Bible is using
good in the same sense that Aristotle
used the word good right creations that
serve their purpose so when you say that
you have a really good car you don't
mean the car is morally good that the
car really gives charity to children you
mean the car works right you mean that
the car does what it is supposed to do
God's creations also serve their various
purposes so in Aristotelian language
human beings are created with the same
thing we are created with the Telos we
are created with a purpose in mind
objects are created with a purpose a
good hammer hammers things good human
reasons according to Aristotle what
makes human beings good is whether they
serve their purpose in the Bible that
would be worship of God mastery of his
world cultivation of the garden right
because people are actually given tests
in the garden God tells them cultivate
the garden God tells them to be fertile
and multiply right but there are certain
things they're supposed to do that
fulfills their good so the Bible itself
establishes man purpose to quote unquote
work and guard the garden that's what it
says so good is not actually contrasted
with evil in this definition good is
just what anything is supposed to do so
things that are good fulfill their
purpose things that are bad or they're
not really bad per se they're just unfit
for use right the contrast is in between
good and bad it's looking good and unfit
for use so the moral world from God's
perspective is constructed in that
fashion that which is moral is that
which we do that fulfills God's purpose
only when we begin to contrast good and
evil and we eat from the tray of that
knowledge that things start to get
confused because only God can know his
own purposes basic tenets of religion
only God really knows what's going on
only God can define that which is good
in the gods sense right in the
Aristotelian sense to that which is
useful to God but human beings we have
an unfortunate tendency to craft our own
moral systems subjectively and then we
contrast that which is good with that
which is evil and we do so from the
perspective of stuff that we think
affects us well versus stuff that we
think affect us poorly but that's our
view not got right we think the pain is
evil unfairness is evil well not
necessarily right those are those are
things that occur in life according to
God maybe those are evil maybe they're
maybe they're unfit and maybe they are
not unfit but they're not evil right
they're good or they're bad but they're
not evil human beings see these things
as evil and that's why the natural
consequence of Adam and Eve eating from
the tree of knowledge is that suddenly
action that was good in the Aristotelian
sense becomes evil in our own eyes so to
take an example I don't actually think
the childbirth was easy and painless
before Adam and Eve said I don't like
that's not human biology it was probably
pretty painful before Adam and Eve
sinned but only now does even actually
perceive childbirth as sorrow and pain
because now she sees stuff that's bad
happening to her as a moral problem
right there is the theodicy problem it's
a problem of God's justice it's a
problem of the moral system of the world
right and that's a problem because she's
no longer trying to reflect the mind of
God now she's trying to project her own
moral system onto the world whereas
before right Adam was already told to
work and presumably he had to sweat when
he worked but now the ground is
quote/unquote cursed for your sake with
the sweat of your face you shall eat
bread until you return to the ground for
you were taken there from for dust you
are and to dust you will return
so Adam now enters this world of
existential angst before work was the
goal of life now it's an obstacle to
pleasure so work is evil pleasure is
good right so things radically change
and human beings become human beings
because they struggle with the failure
of human created moral systems to match
God's moral system and because human
beings have a tendency to sort of
supplant one for the other and to ignore
even the idea of an Aristotelian good by
constructing our own moral frameworks
be objective moral frameworks rather
than attempting to reflect a more
objective moral framework
we actually exile ourselves from reality
and rebel against us and then were
barred from the Garden of Eden
by flaming swords of our own creation
there's no way to get back in because
there's no way for human beings to
actually perceive what God wants and so
we instead supplant our own idea of what
is evil for what for God's idea of what
is good or not good right so what does
it mean that we're going to die upon
eating the tree of knowledge because we
didn't die right human beings didn't die
even in the story itself Adam meet he
lives right he lives for another several
hundred years according to the Bible so
what exactly does die well the part of
us that actually gives us eternal life
that immediate communion with God so the
Bible has this beautiful language when
it talks about the creation of man that
were formed from the clay of the earth
and then God breathes life into us right
this beautiful beautiful image when we
die according to religion and according
to a lot of philosophers the soul
doesn't disappear so long as we use our
earthbound bodies to work in God's
service we're not even separated from
him while we're alive but our bodies
once they become obstacles to our
perception of God well then a part of us
has died Brennan we're now trapped when
a more animal than man right we are
trapped in the same worlds the animals
experience and pleasure and pain driven
by the same instincts that Thomas Hobbes
and David Hume talked about as opposed
to that that attempts to reason that
attempt to rise above that attempt to
commune with a higher level of morality
okay so there is your read on the
beginning of Genesis and I hope that you
enjoyed that and I frankly it's my show
so I guess so what I want so what we'll
do some more of that next week otherwise
you know if you know like you can always
tune out early from the show but I think
that it's important to understand the
Bible I think that it's important to
understand what religious people think
of the Bible and that we are not all
simpletons who simply go around thinking
that snakes talk to people and and say
weird stuff and then they're flaming
swords and all that like there's actual
meaning to these stories which is why
they're so deeply embedded in Western
consciousness okay unfortunately we are
out of time but there are two additional
hours of the Ben Shapiro show coming up
later this is why you should subscribe
I'll do mail bagging it up then so we'll
see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua Olvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all the things that
are really important to you so come join
the conversation
you